at hairspray to get your life together
I'm not touching
Wow and if L said hey here's a workout
all 30 teams right we're doing on my
field it's my decision
all right [ __ ] don't play I think he
thought that the people that he thought
that they weren't going to show him in a
correct light so I guess they wanted to
have my [ __ ] on a job or not
this thing was more freedom of the press
kind of thing
gule gule don't play football yeah don't
bloody playing the XSL
now what about this if you want to play
football then you could do the XFL and
it's starting back up isn't it Darren
yeah they play grab-ass with Vince
McMahon to be number [ __ ] 974 that's
row yeah they do some weird [ __ ] throw
interceptions that no one's gonna
[ __ ] care about you know I'm saying
dude you're talking about Pacman Jones
was in there dude I know he hate me was
out of the PA yeah hell yeah beautiful
guy huh and he uh he did a crime I think
as well didn't need Eric yeah it's the
movie dark history dark history Brendan
well it starts back up again in 2020 uh
he's smart let's dock him racial bro he
just had a history of crime Pat McAfee
is gonna be the announcer to is he yeah
I want to do well cuz that's my boy but
that's gonna be the announcer yeah dude
they're gonna get something people tuned
in just for that oh yeah he's a beast
I'll listen to Padme oh yeah good to see
you man - brother look I'm not about the
Hat dude
thanks ma'am there's a seasonal hat -
and this is a hunting is going on while
Derek's still looking up something from
a couple minutes ago what we about the
hunting is it a hunting season you going
I think it so is it always hunting
season depending what you hunt it's
always on season baby maybe if you're a
scummy shooter hunting these thoughts
you know cutting them catfished okay I'm
broke
if you hunt it's 24/7 they don't see bro
it's fall
big boy fall huntin bro oh you found me
Doug
I'm right here sir look without some
cheese oh really wasn't I want those
things like horses get man blinders yeah
that's how you need me you gotta keep
those thoughts out of your peripheral
yeah you're right
I need this thought blockers dude
there's the sunglasses that keep
thoughts out of your visual blockers bro
blockers Merle owned them things have
you tried them on don't I could teach
right burn survivors god they're amazing
Jeffrey's gone out of business are they
out of business blue blockers ya know
you can still get a pair of something
uncle uncle baby Billy has a pair of day
baby Billy yeah that makes sense
blue block oh there they are Doug Jan
now remember the rap they had over the
video yeah you gotta kill it just sounds
homeless if you do three stands about
sunglasses right you out li market
apparently and this dude just started
freestyling then blue bars like that's a
new commercial shoot it do didn't get
any blood lockers were the best man and
they blocked out a lot of colors the
only color they gave you was yellow so
they really blocked out or they really
blocked out green they let a little
orange in so they blocked out green
where I'm at night too Brandon I'm doing
the colors this locked out green purple
purple orange no we're ready orange red
black white brown light gray white beige
that's not one of them pink and a couple
of other colors at the end they blocked
out everything except for orange and a
little bit of yellow dude so the whole
world was kind of it's kind of gray I
think a lot of people got depressed
wearing them you know I'm saying what
was this great everybody orange dude it
looked like somebody spilled Gatorade
all over your whole life that beautiful
orange flavors and Sun in your eyes you
don't say dude oh it was good man what
do you got that pink outfit huh yeah
what's up dawg
dude that's ski yeah I like the Hat I
like the whole wardrobe today bro what's
hunting season Derek any day Jack
Sparrow [ __ ] dumber Fudd damn sex-toy
dude dude you're gonna suck the boys off
in a country western that now boys see
it the trough boys PS I'll be the troll
you shouldn't do a country-western show
is disgusting dude I just said trough
and need to get another level bro with
that hat I expect that but that color
you're that pink only comes in [ __ ]
butt-plug color dude that is wholly a
sex toy a color dude who did you rob
Tommy Lee's closet there's no injectable
watching this right I go on that thing
say well it's for hunting you Derek
season five days a year
yeah yeah bro keep my eye on the [ __ ]
what about hunting what do you know
anything about hunting is it are you a
hundred uh huh
put a dude I'll put a Mallard in a
leglock dog arrow through your thick ass
Flintstones head from [ __ ] hundred
yards away son stupids arrow that's what
they would call it bro here's what I'm
saying is this dude I'll put a hard
scarf on a [ __ ] antelope dog
somebody's going down bro art scarf
problem with my arms and legs I don't
hunt like some hoe with the [ __ ]
little whatever [ __ ] bazooka bro
yeah bazooka bazooka you want to put a
bomb on somebody go over there and set
it on their back do while they're
resting you don't shoot from 289 yards
away man you sneak up on them and I can
put a dynamite right in them hell yeah
Derrick sees in September and October
oh so you're safe now Oh tweet season
it's right now you're up bro what's a
muzzle loader see all right
you're also up again bro
I need a muzzleloader season early bear
season seems like more like something
from West Hollywood
early bear season what are you guys
hungry guys flare-up with uh uh yeah bro
Iwo Jima no Dawa huh
not the ZOA no what no not sushi or you
hunt fish yes hot tuna the water cattle
maybe it's water cattle those whales bro
every now and then if you're lucky a
water buffalo wow those are dangerous if
you really suck at hunting you'll take
chopsticks and just kind of poke at
insects on trees and then you deal with
the polar ice really [ __ ] yeah
is that an old like a traditional really
yeah that's all right off the branch I
don't have like a bowl of rice
chopsticks and then you go from tree to
tree and just kind of find insects t Wow
for reals cut yes I was disturbed when I
first saw this I think it's cuz I'm
American
when I came I was like what the [ __ ] is
that sounds like ferngully - it was
weird yeah I mean you got to do with
what you got yeah he like larvae and
like caterpillars with rice way didn't
make it through larvae thanks bro it was
early are you taking this this turns at
40 50 miles an hour others that stay on
huge impediment brows apiece Michael
that's real cat you guys really going
trees with a ball right he's do that
you've heard of this huh well I got like
that was joke and I was like I should go
now it's a little too real do you find
an anthill that's a damn Thanksgiving
over there do you and a couple buddies
happen upon an ant Idol that could be
lunch if you have that patience man
they have though they have a we're just
so spoiled here I think what like
everything comes in a package
everything's clean nothing has on it
speak for yourself bro when I was a kid
I used to eat red ants and black ants
and I'd lie to my friends say the red
ones taste like cinnamon the black ones
taste like chocolate realize that kid in
the neighborhood
I'd also drink the water through the
gutter gutter yeah bro Wow I'll wait for
it to rain is just whoo
they'll part I don't believe about that
is where we have friends early on in the
story yeah maybe was just my brother and
his friend watching me eat in you know
your brothers kept putting on different
outfits saying he was different friends
holy [ __ ] you're right dude
but that means you love you and he cares
yeah there's a lot of effort something
beautiful about it he had some really
cool accents you know lady yeah it's a
nice tits too a bit Jay's got all tits
in his arm
loosing that guy's biceps bro rest in
peace Rick and Beth Chapman in each
freaking arm huh
that dudes got those straight [ __ ]
yes Don yeah Roseanne and each [ __ ]
oh yeah I was in Vietnam one time or Nam
as I like to call it and we we we went
to a market and they we ordered a while
order to dub order to the Dov right so
insulting and they have all kind of
animals you can get anything you want
it's all living right there so I'm
thinking I'm gonna get this Dov I'm
gonna rescue it right I'm gonna let it
loose
right [ __ ] yeah it was a nice clean
white dove oh this thing was beautiful
but I was heaven bro people have been
smoking around this was a little bit
yellow around the edge of the feathers
like around the tinge I made sense but
it was predominantly white man so he and
smoke too and I don't know about that
yeah but or maybe I don't know they have
their lungs are so small I can't imagine
they're only gonna live two years anyway
who cares that they [ __ ] smoke but
what I'm thinking about is that the oh
so I get it I free it I run outside and
free it the second it leaves my hands
literally six dudes jump on it Wow or
their hand owners bro this dude is that
[ __ ] bench of stretch though it was
over [ __ ] snapped its neck threw it
on his back a real little dude just kept
going and just walked off heading home
bro then jump on scooter we yeah a lot
of scooters out there a lot of lot of
scooter oh yeah that's how you got
around noon [ __ ] yeah dude don't they
have like deep-fried or not deep-fried
don't they have like chocolate dipped
cockroaches and [ __ ] chocolate dipped
I'm not yeah that's how I work I think
that's a sterling the Harry Potter man
this is Vietnam I might even get him
confused okay no guys that's Gotham City
on his globe over here he thought Peter
Parker was the mayor of Chicago this is
today but that's crying that do people
are so brave enough to walk around and
just be like all right oh they crack
open a big piece of bark and there's a
beehive and they're saying let's get in
there with rice yeah right yeah and they
still do it to this day to this day
isn't there forest in Japan where just
people commit suicide like it's the spot
to go to yeah just a bunch of trees why
there I don't know exactly why I think
it's just an easy place to kind of
walking get lost
have you seen have you seen that
strength in numbers man I've seen it
dude look man it's no fun to die alone
you know and widespread panic said it
and I'll say this I picked up a
hitchhiker
one time and he told me a story he told
me of a story another time a guy picked
him up and this guy I've been
hitchhiking by for decades I guess and
he probably I'm really going anywhere
which is the shocking part about most of
them you're just going in circles
this guy just [ __ ] bothered you're
paying a canyon to be in circles yeah
dude
and uh he told me he goes one time a guy
picked me up and he was in a high-speed
chase from the police hell yeah and I
said well why'd you pick me up in the
guy said because I don't want to die
alone that's what he said imagine you
get pick up your hitchhiking in the dude
who's picking herbs in a heist is also a
movie called
the chase was it really yeah I remember
we picked up that hot chick in the chase
and then they [ __ ] and there's cops
behind him oh it might been important I
saw no there this with a homeboy uh the
chase huh oh dude and just a hot girl
and she's like he kidnaps her cuz he
doesn't wanna be alone right and she's
all rich and her dad's like the governor
some [ __ ] and she's smoking hot then
they fall in love with the cops behind
him they like about to run out of gas
she [ __ ] them favorite movies owns a
great love story bro dude 37 seven
rotten tomatoes suck my yeah finger dude
juice it's a muzzle season baby that's
what I'm saying load them up I'll throw
a [ __ ] grenade into a dam do we
should redo the chase Cabbage Patch yeah
we should redo the chase man but
nobody's [ __ ] at the end no we just
become best friends yeah do we become
best friends that don't have to spend
that much time together though because
there also have to stay busy yeah we're
gonna separate once we get away from the
cops then we just separate yeah in our
busy lives you know we do hang out
sometimes and we also get together
sometimes yeah every Tuesday to do a
show yeah and we chat about it there -
yeah we chat with your texts how about
these hats did you see the Jersey god
that's beautiful the lake monsters
Romana clusters my boy Jeff Kent oh boy
what a great name for a team the lake
monsters on the boat yeah dude monsters
in the front names on the back
back yeah that's cool thanks Jeff thanks
Jeff Kent yeah Superman Jeff Kent the
baseball player
same guy wow they're affiliated with the
Oakland A's them Lake Monsters huh oh
yeah dude
also back to Vietnam there's a little
animal over there that'll swim up your
wiener and cause havoc for your whole
life
tell us cat and if you eat this thing
you are really a risky woman now that's
the same thing Mexico I hate to keep
going back to Mexico it's all I know huh
cuz that thing can swim but your
[ __ ] too now it burns so first of
all don't drink tequila through your
wiener can you look that up things
time's up man's Weiner yeah it's a
parasite in the water now if you're
swimming Vietnam you're asking for
trouble bro one thing you know doing
Vietnam I learned this when I was young
kid you don't swim in fresh water
because of those parasites swim predict
cool
I mean don't hang out ladyboys or you
tie something off a lot of times people
will tie like I put a little piece of
gum in the end of their penis or do a um
like a stop I put a little tic-tac in my
people and do what dudes but he's the
boys his muzzle season season his mother
I got low yeah I got loaded up and
gunned down and see that common man lake
monster suzuka Joe thanks for menthe
you'd always wanted to go to Vermont
I heard it's beautiful hmm they had that
nice maple syrup out there you know
sucking out of the tree baby yeah [ __ ]
yeah you know her Vermont eatery with
chopsticks if you know Kat should get a
bowl of rice all right sweeten the deal
yeah man if amber on Christmas imagine
you find a treatise full of bugs and
just put your lips right on that [ __ ]
and to suck as hard as you can ah
kouno Matala baby that's from sambro
means no worries when i was a young
warthog
way too believable didn't it I've
watched too much dude my son loves that
[ __ ] it was a young warthog right your
son emailed me and said he's not a lot
of watts of television because you've
been hogging it I told Matt uncie what's
up with you guys what's going on Derrick
oh man you got me freaked out about this
penis book it's called the candor ooh
keep your ass out of Vietnam bro it's a
real face yeah or if you also now this
can't you can't get this from making
love to a Vietnamese woman can you no no
no it's a sweat on their hands
Wow it really depends that Vietnamese
girls is that your type huh that I think
so I don't know I thought I have like a
kind of a chart I maybe I was a little
younger but I would have to me too I'm
open to it yeah and I feel like guys and
girls don't like me
mmm I'm just some dude I love Asian
girls you do
yeah middle school and said what's your
type is but hot I still believe that
after all these years
really yes I'm gonna type hot hot chicks
yeah black white asian hot dust smokin
damn like brisket baby oh I like that
strong you know I like a strong woman
wing really yeah like a woman ooh just
cry like a woman who at least if the car
breaks down she's gonna get out and look
at me fix the tire if that [ __ ] stays
in there that's [ __ ] we never going out
again that's fair
there's two types of women at least I
want the woman that stands out there and
looks worried yeah I feel that yeah at
least come out and let me know what's
going on you know I'm saying yeah I
don't want to just stay in the car wait
you all the worse for adding weight to
the [ __ ] car
yeah I have to pump up out in the best
she's on this be MDM and dude you're
fixing the tire this sounds like a
biography brand what a [ __ ] all right
feeling the [ __ ] another show we should
do the own the [ __ ]
oh ho dude I'd meet you in the middle of
a spaghetti
yami-chan spaghetti if we're in prison I
would hundred percent dude you and me
together together bro but spending time
occasionally I would do that I wish will
be but we'll be bunk mates
I'll be your ready oh you oh you're Andy
Dufresne right I'm red you're Andy
Dufresne I'm red is that a word Tech
American yeah I got it is he a bruisin I
wish I wish I could say Andy fall off
the ladyboys I wish I could say he won
every fight but he didn't remember that
use like anything you put in my mouth
it's coming down by now yeah Jesus
yeah what they bought the ladies lady
boys they become the lady boys no that's
what they're called the lady lady boys
yeah boy he was relentless wasn't he a
lady boy yeah but if this Shawshank I'm
red you're Andy Dufresne 100% I'm Brooks
was here day time I hang myself listen
any more of this [ __ ] bro I'm getting a
job at the supermarket for two days and
then I'm [ __ ] axe in myself sir can I
go to the bathroom come here you don't
need to ask you have to go the bathroom
every goddamn time just go yeah and then
he goes back and he writes his name in
the wall and it goes the center why not
that okay cat would even up to let's you
know Stevie King wrote that by the way
no he didn't if they did wrote ready for
work then we wrote a Shawshank
Redemption yep you have the bone Wow so
much better than the [ __ ] he writes on
Twitter did you hear him on Twitter
yeah why would I follow Twitter hell no
yeah you're right I don't know why idea
I got to get some is he crying on
Twitter at all to realize I come for the
comedy yeah I don't need your input on
Trump and [ __ ] every day every day every
day Stephen King right at 3:00 shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah that's what your honor - do not cry
about politic new chance for a couple
mutants Mutantes
cat what's up in your world I'm feeling
really in touch with my culture today oh
wow thank you
why is that just holidays everybody's
kind of talking about it everyone's
talking about Vietnam I feel really
close to everyone right now that has the
bus lamp shirt on by and do we have
those available yeah quatre we're gonna
come out with those soon right I'm out
with those soon oh really yeah we're
gonna have all new merch store in the
new year
do those bustling shirts are do we
should just get a one big bus lamp in
the middle deposit on your own time well
we know who's gonna fill it up probs
post and look at them Jesus man juice
we're in Salt Lake City this week the
post man what a lake monster monster
I'll start a lake right there dude and
lake monsters and this and the thing
that crawls up your wiener everything
just full circle again that's the big
man upstairs come full circle that's the
Lord brother the Lord's work the lake
monster Jesus Christ is a gangster man
he's a blood in a [ __ ] dude he bled any
[ __ ] rolled out of the crib
think about the head bro you throw up
gang signs yeah man
dude that's what I'm saying bro ms70 dog
the big dog you know it's weird to think
about it some people think he was white
you think he won't light just like it
look at the location geographically he
there no white man would have been in
that area doesn't make sense
he is Santana than me bro bro he was
probably tan good chance any it's here
like Walt Lanza black you mean he look
like more like Derek than you skin a
copper baby
well copper also he'd been in the Sun
for yeah but a few hundred years 300
years you're a real white guy burn yeah
so seeing that I'm part of the land you
feel me I think he got tanned up dude
he's like me I get super tan you do yeah
I hate to give you a tan lines or not
dapper dude he'd always stay Brown
year-round damn that's a rap line well
well uh should we take this thing off
you guys might get going
I forget what we're doing yeah I don't
you know what we're doing dude looking
at this thing
[ __ ] yeah now it's everyone's favorite
time it's a commercial from King in the
state do
I don't know if you notice what my hair
is getting egg bro
well I'm family what I'm using bro huh
are you really what are you using him
stewed are using him Sims because
because are you really yeah Wow cuz I'm
a thicker I want I just want to keep
going I don't know how long I'm gonna
take it do I cut a mullet eventually and
we become be with somebody head real
life action figure yeah maybe thanks to
him just leave look at the curls out the
back bro oh dude thanks damn said a few
more hands you'll be a hers bro oh that
hams it's thick man if you want to
tighten up your body tighten up your
hair make your skin thicker making make
your wiener feel more enticing and feel
make your body feel tighter and leaner
and longer and you want to feel
everything in your body reaching for God
then you can go with him ya can start
losing your hair 66% of men by 35 what
are we doing you want to hold on to that
frickin body textile dog you want to
hold on to that hair yeah this Black
Friday next week secure the best deal of
all a healthier thick old hair line
everybody yep
no snake oil or gas station counter
supplements none of that smokey rhino or
whatever that junk is brother stuff that
makes you nosebleed just talking real
real decent stuff prescription solutions
backed by science though is what science
no more awkward in-person doctor visits
no way listen all you do is four hands
connection a real doctor online which
could save you hours all right
hours a few quick question about your
stupid hairline and doctor will review
it and they decide what to give you it's
sent directly to your house all discreet
nobody knows nobody knows yeah bro
nobody knows bro a table knows bro but
everybody knows dude bo knows this
Thanksgiving when you're up say hey
sweet here they're talking about you
dude their time by you not the turkey
okay guy what I'm gonna say is this dude
look thicken the hair look thicken the
stick get your body right get your skin
warm do it all with hims
I'm trying for free bro let them try it
for free right pop I'll give it to them
for free what I'm saying right now is
try him today for free go to online go
to for hemes calm / k8
ts that's fo r hims dot-com slash cats
for hemes dot-com slash cats see website
for full details and safety info
remember that's for hems comm slash it's
picking up support the podcast
dude I'm sick of this watch bro I need
something sweet I thought I want for
Christmas dude is a new watch they just
don't make them like they used to
oh when I was young the watches you
would even at some point say it was just
like too little you would draw what time
it was in your hand and then tell people
dude thank God for movement watches has
you covered this season with hundreds of
watches blue like glasses Sony's jewelry
whatever you need the perfect stocking
stuffer stuff that stock and look em VMT
are the watches that we're talking about
and they are phenom his-and-her gift
guides a free quick shipping right to
your door yes style too these days it's
all about your style quit copying off of
this guy copying off a dead guy or
somebody they might die yeah I guess
what save money movement watches start
at just 95 bucks clean design quality
product movement has sold over 2 million
watches what be the big winner this
holiday with a gift from movement get
15% off today with free shipping free
returns by going to MVM t.com slash cats
movement means movement if you want to
move then move show what you do get that
timepiece keep that clock on your
frickin arm move out the way go to nvm
t-dot-com
slash cats join the moment someone got
spayed for Theo's haircut alright let's
switch it up this week boy sparked with
King inner sting it this week we'll
start with it first Jackson Ross this
big Jack Co dirt
Brendan swabs got a kid Gator sting in
here for you health in a nice place
acoustic guitar oh now I would send you
guys a video of me playing but the see
big you know and that's a cat instead
you know what can I say shooter shoot
anyway
pack shoutout feel shadow Brennan love
you guys get gank buzz buzz buzz party
arms Harvey Oswald's fine fat cat
shooter shoot alright John Stockman
stupid shooter that dudes firing huh
that's why there's a little teriyaki on
that arrow cat you feel me what that's a
Chinese sauce dude sauce a little wasabi
on that air okay
little ginger uh wasabi little shashka
Juan acoustic guitar bro I'm a straight
man but nothing gets my dick moist like
a nice sound of a classic guitar bro
Perry's got here John Mayer start
playing bro my love is pure dude I used
to live with this man for a while and at
night I knew a couple of songs on the
get he'd have me come in here and play
something for him in this Nicki lady he
was rubbing down yeah like oh really you
know what I could play pretty decently
in college and I would have to go in
there and play him a couple melodies at
night while I fell asleep no that's cool
there's part of my rental detail part of
my detail over there and I slipped on
the couch and I have to listen to them
do sex all the time and it made me so
nervous but that but your guitar got it
made me nervous your I would get them in
the mood like one elephant asleep Eric
Clapton with some puzzle you and Yvonne
I must be strong in carry on cuz I move
you don't be long I don't know that song
what else you getting here in a pong
what else dude but you play your body's
a wonderland with your pain you got Dan
it no I would play a little widespread
panic sipping on a tall boy that would
wake him up how does that go so I'd
really just play there cotton went over
and over again I do I love acoustic
guitars solid steel in the dead of the
night I wish you bring the guitar in
here bro
oh yeah we'd bring it here man that's
[ __ ] long armed harmonic
shred city boy they might not even a
minute again damn guitar you got four
guitars in two arms dude who are you
fooling brough share your [ __ ] you know
there's a lot going on there man be a
share bear you want to get in a cat's
heart you got a share bro get in there
you know what I'm saying it's a thing
but you kill a pigeon right on your
[ __ ] doorstep that [ __ ] ran out
there and bite its [ __ ] be cuff you
know what the thing about guitars the
thing about guitars is you can be ugly
as [ __ ] if you can play that thing oh
yeah
automatically 6 points like you're at
heart 3 guitar 9 yes that Lea Ed Sheeran
oh no talent can't sing to that guitar
skills Hawk 10 even with this crooked
ass [ __ ] guy bad bad eyes damn know if I
can see 360 like chameleon he's the
ginger Little John brah here's what I'm
saying is I think Ed Sheeran's a
beautiful man dude he's got hair like a
damn uh he's got a hey he's like he's a
real hair aqui but I look at him he
looks like something I would swim right
up your penis and if I can give you an
infection but look I'll tell you this
man the guy's got beautiful music
goddamn I've danced with a man at one of
his songs once this is the same guy used
to play music for nope together hear
that man was in the bigger gals dude I
had to go pick him up for him too I had
to drive his truck cause he like he
liked him trunk you got a DWI yeah what
kind of trunk you were talking here I'm
talking about like Liz oh I'm talking
about you talking Liz oh are we talking
like Beyonce you ever had too many
McGriddle in a bag and the bag starts to
rip at the top where you're trying to
hold it what what a great reference yeah
and get soggy and you know that bad
ain't gonna hold you gotta hold it back
with your bottom yeah with that bottom
man yeah that's a great reference bro so
just a kind of unique woman her fully
you know fully acclimated to her skin
that's getting about the pop but what do
I know
what are you guys up to these days cat
just in general do you like this man
this white man this musician he seems
like a very nice man he doesn't he's
handsome right [ __ ] together
do you been talking about serenading
some dude for most your life I had to
brown out did yeah yeah other ways I
think I was in college I was scaring
apart with a 50 year old man it was a
one-bedroom I was another college
student have any money you [ __ ] you
think everybody has money that is gets a
liver they want so you have to play
music seem to play music that'll be nice
once a week he'd have the lady come over
man maybe twice a week
dude I was shooter brought the guitar I
was just kid with a song did he slip
slip in your DMS cat and play some tunes
I don't know here's what we would love
then I think he should have to serenade
huh or even do a king of sing sexy song
so he can play a bro dude I hear theme
song yeah I say you serenade are a
little Siamese cat over here and send in
a love ballad and we'll play it on here
hello you can uh can go it or veto it
whatever she wants to do yeah you better
be able to play with all them goddamn
guitars - what's your Axl Rose what you
have so many [ __ ] guitars but if he
works at like the the the the Music Hall
of Fame and he just walk him out when
the hinds good point he might even play
this yeah my artist his dad his dad
maybe Eric Clapton or some [ __ ] dude his
dad could have passed away dude well
it's a nice crib too though he might be
a successful musician we just said yeah
he does Lee could be success could be
and Fall Out Boy I have no idea its life
looks nice hmm
hell yeah he looks like CB Dollaway old
school reference well if he wants to
fall out into these Vietnamese for jeans
over here what I'm saying is this dude
needs to tighten up with a sweet
serenade yeah if you wanna fall out and
cats titties
go ahead and hit that tune son yeah yeah
yeah those cats at Tet Tet's oh sorry
cat you're gonna play that in court one
to hate and when you do that at the end
that's gonna really judge like ten to
fifteen Jesus Christ and you're gonna do
it one more time and then as we walk out
the bailiff will reach over and go buzz
buzz keep touching me don't touch me I
get it
do not get in trouble all right what
else
next we got Jordan Hamilton this is big
Jordan J hambone this dude's been doing
drugs let's see him J hammies oh [ __ ]
are those rats audio come again got a
king understand actual rats do you say
the Rat King
let's see him rat-a-tat-tat he's going
through some [ __ ] hey come out rat [ __ ]
he's off
they are rats do you like him I do bro
he's getting that [ __ ] in the Lord's
massage having two rats running running
your shoulder that'd be Satan's massage
the Lord massages - pigeons [ __ ]
dude rats are freaking bunnies in
disguise bro that's the old that's what
the old saying you know they're not
there this [ __ ] scene mice of the
underworld dude they can [ __ ] standing
up bro and you're strong ones can [ __ ]
on one leg some know martial arts shout
to splinter there's a thing about rats
dude they carry so many diseases fun
funny you know there's more rats in the
United States and our people but imagine
this though and that's not true that's a
nice try though no watch the rats
documentary huh
the rats documentary you believe that
stuff it's propaganda now you kind of
right on that it is propaganda huh yeah
how many rats are there you are
unbelievable how you made it through
school Derek honestly
come on bro yeah my bad bro you know I
like that stereotype that you'll soon
know I look right I assume kappa yeah
who knows if any of us made it through
school they mean Catalonian was a
degrees in here but whatever stereotype
you're running a fever and that's the
only degrees you [ __ ] god boy me
Academy only if people with diplomas
breath okay you were indeed keep
touching me dude
dear will you tell us something chin
over here with a [ __ ]
there's a billion of them on the planet
China believed to have more than two
billion right well that doesn't make
sense there's a zillion there's billions
of them on the planet we're trying to
believe to have through to bill also
there's more than human look at the fact
he googled how many rats are there of
course you guys are [ __ ] on the middle
of the freeway out here oh man I'm gonna
say this how hard would it be to have so
much disease in your body and still show
up to work every day making it through
the pipes looking for the cheese smiling
occasionally there's some videos where
they smile
yeah I've seen can you imagine that you
just be loaded down with Ebola a black
body ate holy a Black Plague polio
syphilis syphilis herpes herpes
gonorrhea gonorrhea ade say capital AIDS
chicken pox chicken pox and you're not
even a [ __ ] chicken and you wake up
every day the flu with the flu the bird
flu the bird they don't have that yeah
imagine having mad town not being a cow
and just being mad unbelievable yeah
rats dude they're survivors that's what
I'm saying bro so that one is Nana make
it yeah
[ __ ] Beyonce's bro these are the Li
no Jerry no Jamie Knowles or whatever
that lady's name is Eileen Knowles Oh
Kelly knows what she do these days
Beyonce was like CEO losers
Oh Kelly still sings what was this guy's
question am i doing I'm doing okay
brother and I'll respect a man there
look they do their best dude you know I
like that you have clean rats I'll give
you that yeah mm-hmm
not now probably if I put the rats down
don't go talk to some real humans though
man just kind of feel your way out there
maybe a nice young lady to help you
watch some rats down the road okay yeah
there's cat lady's in that that doesn't
end well for them they get very lonely
then there's rat boys that also doesn't
end well rats come see he's got rats in
your apartment yeah your rats got no one
to talk to watching reruns of Animaniacs
and [ __ ] get sad bro you start having
junior rats in your [ __ ] apartment
that's insane bro we start having
second-generation rat yeah if you're
dealing with the second third
generations of rat such as like a giant
a little yeah tight now you got to get
us a Gore you got to get a you know you
got to take go for a couple of walks or
something refined like a chilly place in
your buyers just like to put the cheese
puffs down [ __ ] quit watching Teen
Mom and get and go meet some ladies now
I've got this guy's a fine-ass chick
dude got chicks love guys that have
animals like interesting pets agree for
the most part rats I tried Prai is this
one just listen I'm putting my detective
hat on it's probably you know you know
what you know there's no woman in that
apartment there easily could be a
[ __ ] beautiful hot chick behind one
of this I can't have little rats one of
those walls kidnapped nation that's
though they're survivors I'm taking this
Lake myself only cuz I want to show off
my shirt that I've worked today yeah I
like you do thank you it's a nice shirt
it's a nice shirt do Maya someone got me
this one time
really yeah oh yeah we lake monsters dog
I'll see you in deep right field dude
hell yeah pass for the parents Park that
sorry these to make me play you know
your shitty has sports they put you in
[ __ ] the outfield and pop wanna oh
yeah and literally they put me in way
out feel
working occasion I remember one inning
don't give it up to every now and then
one of the coaches would throw it out
there to me so I could do something
brand make an idea the game was over but
I was always working for us the orange
slices going to play to be dude I'll
tell you what man or don't tell me
something every time you tell me to do I
don't want to tell you though I got me
to tell you but I have to tell you oh no
bro because I got this buzz I've got
this budge dude you just to get a bush
on top I know both Oh sometimes
sometimes I use it just doesn't grow on
top my hair grows everywhere you got to
take care of one of them man you can't
be running both here's the problem I'm
sick of nicking my nuts are you I'm
using the beard trim around my nuts it's
getting all snipped up
it looks like Freddy Krueger down there
dude oh wow you got to use something
special man yeah what do you got bro use
a hard spoon brother but if you don't
then what I'm saying is used manscaped
manscaped offer precision engineer tool
for your family jewel yeah it's time to
gear up and get yourself the gift of
shaving this holiday season give your
dick a philly fade i'm talking about the
manscape perfect package 2.00 trim
around your wiener like a damn artistic
champion dude I'm talking about Vincent
van Gogh Picasso you're nuts redesign
the electric trimmer they did what yeah
a lot more 2.0 what are we doing you
won't Nick or snag your nuts any more
you're gonna win Best in Show on that
[ __ ] and Wien bro no doubt about it dude
Congrats get your trophy now all right
that manscape perfect package 2.0
includes the crop preserver at the anti
chafing ball deodorant and moisturizer
do you have a husband a friend a son
that's getting thick maybe a nice coach
yeah whatever you got man take care of
there jump peep this the manscaped
perfect package 2.0 includes a crop
preserver anti chafing ball deodorant a
pair of boxer briefs all right
plus the trimmer blood get torn off free
shipping with the code cats at manscape
calm that's right get something special
this holiday time do something special
get 2000 and free shipping with the code
cats at manscape calm that's why first
off free shipping at manscape dot-com
use the code cats cleanup you're not to
make Santa proud
gang [ __ ] time to buy few more pants
tell me something
maybe dude I've spent a lot of time in
the car I don't live close well you know
I like to buy I know it I know you let
me just say the books bro Brendon likes
his books loud the only guy who every
one time he was driving he's like hey
man crank up that book the windows in
crank up this Hemingway you did a little
more bass in your Moby Dick that's what
you need bro here's what I'm saying that
audible have the world largest selection
of audio books and audio entertainment
yeah man they got documentaries
exclusive audiobooks and scripted shows
that can that you anywhere vacation home
car whatever you want with the Kamiya
audible app you can listen anytime
anywhere on any device mobile alexa
bluetooth whatever you want mobile
immobile in a wheelchair in a treehouse
downhill uphill hidden it under the
stairs nobody cares boy you can listen
to a book yeah audible members get more
than ever before every month you can
choose one audible book regardless of
price as well as two audible originals
from a fresh selection members stay
motivated by inspired with unlimited
access to exclusive guided fitness
meditation programs sign up for free
updates from the New York Times Wall
Street Journal whatever you want look if
you want to be with sait and be with
Satan but if you don't want to then what
i'm saying is go to audible.com use one
out of your book and one out herbal
original absolutely free visit
audible.com like I say an audible huh
I don't like I say an audio either dude
now you know how I feel bro Powell of
the time Wow okay interesting
dude I'll choose one audiobook to
audible originals absolutely free visit
audible.com slash cats or text cats -
500 - 500 for bet bro isn't it alpha
yeah maybe you're right yeah let's write
it out someone's got to pay for
Brennan's coffee habit you know written
my drip
like this is love and Dan from Orange
County
big a OD oh wow
can you zoom in a little bit arc is that
Hilfiger that's what I was wondering and
I would see what is that what's he
holding their wine he's got a bottle of
Rosa he's got a cigarette and he has a
12-gauge it looks like he definitely
listens to Uncle Kracker come with me
he's definitely out of contest with a
buddy to see how many pieces a cinnamon
gum they could take in their mouth at
once
drives a Thunderbird I bet he drives
actual funder this dude if I can see I'm
like in the school shootings this dude
definitely bug and I bet his arm kind of
reaches you know just automatically
lifts up towards his uh towards his own
towards his hip yeah when he passes a an
elementary school this guy's got a bad
bad tune in his bucket yeah there's a
bad guy look at him this guy's a bad guy
and he's telling us hit burnin look at
him oh dude I was gonna say it before
he's go down when I can tease wearing
sandals with jeans and for him it's
always hunting season hmm just not
during spring break you know I'm saying
Google has been said haha
Leigha dirtiest feet on bro yeah is this
did this come with is this a manifesto
what kind of picture this guy in Fresno
recently all right Peter this guy might
be a missing person do worst Jaycee Lee
Dugard bro that's what I want to know
who's that girl he got kidnapped me uh
this guy looks like he's pissed limp
Biskit is gone this guy I like one
biscuit for a second there I still like
him yeah it's all about the new you know
what there's no you what
now I don't like I'm ready to wear just
a red Yankee that yeah I wanted one I
had to have one time that was nice it
was a Chicago Blackhawks hat and man I
loved it man
what happened to it I notice Florida
Panthers okay no what happened there
rivalries but whatever don't happen to
it okay King this guy all right so this
is Isabella from Dallas Texas
okay a 23 year old entertainer
entertainers in quotes and do she loves
you your favorite and they want about
strippers they want you to rate that
stripper bro great my strip now which
one is Izzy on the left of the right I
believe is he is our girl on the with
the rainbow with the rainbow too - okay
okay got that thick rainbow all right
that tastes the rainbow that ROYGBIV huh
it's um the king-sized freakin skittles
baby that's those uh now and laters
remember toes [ __ ] yeah
they weren't that great no they weren't
they look like a box of runts over here
these are two young women trying to make
it in society now the one on the Left
can get it though she wants to share
well she was sure about your [ __ ]
Mike and Ikes hit me up girl what does
that mean run a train who's Ike bro
here's what I'm saying I'm Mike and Ike
do both of these ladies one of them is
wearing a nightie one of them is wearing
more of like a has very like a kind of a
clownish sort of outdoorsy maybe Raven
Meyers
brave they look like two chicks that
went to fire festival and [ __ ] God
dis up we near you're still there though
they're still there and
I'm gonna get back yeah they look like a
couple of fire festival lifers yeah
still still doing live instagrams from
fire festival
it says Jim just barbecue and outdoors
but a couple of them just barbecue and
coconut now tell you what man the
probably thing the same thing I want to
go on making afraid just lose the pounds
that's what it takes for me lose weight
I'll do it they get afraid I could see
you on there bro I'll get my cheeks out
I don't want that I just want to see how
you survive you and I could do naked
afraid but you don't go to us to be
naked you could be naked at home you
delinquent now you go to be afraid yeah
I would be afraid of the dark nobody's
there just like the first day this
modeling or right on the leg it would be
pull-ups on the tree if I can I'm
excited for this and then don't bring a
hot chick man I don't get how the dudes
just aren't like I don't know what to
tell you I've seen [ __ ] hyenas all
goddamn week you and your fine ass comes
up with this blonde ass oh you mean it
for chick what do you mean
don't bring a hot chick or do or what do
you say what do you mean I'd like a hot
chick there but then also forgive me you
know I'm saying no I don't that's why
I'm asking you I don't understand
exactly what you're I'm saying I'm
trapped on this island right 21 days but
naked yeah with some like dime piece me
prom son dude no dime is going on there
without some mental issues I don't thing
going on naked and afraid
exactly so these two need to figure it
out they need to figure it out Lord what
are the thoughts is that where you going
Lord of the thighs that's panning down
honestly I think these bad [ __ ] are
on drugs dude
and I'm drug free and so I can't be out
there out there watching y'all do all
the dust and everything out there and
licking each other's thighs and ass you
know not one on left let's get a bag of
pop rocks and figure it out girl now Kat
what do you got to say when you see
these types of ladies oh I love it
Asian girls always come dressed like
that for raves always and do Asians love
rays is there
yes wonjun's love raves ecstasy hell
yeah [ __ ] clothes and fake tits yeah
yeah yeah I'm a giant asian girl yeah
dude we found something new
[ __ ] yeah what uh so uh that's great
ever been to rave huh
yeah yeah yeah you just have way bad
Wednesday they beat something out with a
chain at it one time like this is
horrible dude I want to rave one time
there's eight people it's sad it's in
Hollywood there's eight people we stayed
up all night man that's not a ray dude
he may be right but there's a DJ though
bumpin up on I hung up on a button I was
on the dance floor like this oh I got
caught at a place looking for dope one
time with some lady I remember what
happened and I don't know man I don't
know what happened
well King these ladies yeah what do they
need money to for the fare
uber home what's going on here thank you
ladies to the love y'all seem like
decent women and I think at a certain
point I like strippers now if there's
strippers here look get out there and
make your money but also I think you
need to have some sort of long-term exit
strategy because at some point the tits
don't lie sometimes the tits give up and
your ass falls back you know I'm saying
then eat then the money stops that's
yeah that's what I'm saying - yeah so
but I didn't know I always agen girls
always made me feel like they're not
interested I think because I don't know
their vibe at all you know like white
girls and black girls I can tell more
their vibe because I grew up around them
Asians always look the same like I never
know what I don't know cats in a good
mood or bad mood really always looks the
same no I don't think that I think I can
tell it's not a racial thing but it's
good I know Katla better maybe it's cuz
I don't know a lot but yeah a lot of
Asian girls they say it never seemed
interested they never look at you dude I
got you do just start talking about
anime they freak the [ __ ] out
really oh dude it's such a turn-on I
don't know anything about it me neither
just say Pokemon or some [ __ ] uh-uh not
be amazing Pokemon again Oh whoo
how old are these women I don't know see
that's nothing you don't know their age
either well I'm gonna know I see doesn't
it sounds like it does yeah Jesus
good luck with the Asians yeah me mmm
good luck not turning your diary over to
police yeah you're in trouble what else
do we have to do here man because I
don't know what's going on a little
relationship advice maybe you guys
college it would help so many people
it's an Asian many people send me a
death threat cuz she told him to fake
like he was Christian to get with this
girl I was good advice to that kid with
braces what else you got all right we
got our boy this is Zack Zack Kennedy I
know he might be what up boys is that
coming to you live from Fisher's Ville
Virginia I don't I need some
relationship advice from you fellas
currently in a relationship with a girl
who's going to PA school and recently
she has asked me to help her with a
colonoscopy exam mm-hmm that means she's
gonna have to stick her finger in my ass
you know I I really like her just cool
you know but I just I just don't know if
I'm ready to get a finger stuck in my
ass like that like just well just to be
you know violating the xposed I mean
yeah
Lydon but you know he he didn't give me
a warning now that I have a warning I
kind of don't want to do it you gotta
live anyways let me know what you guys
think I should or should not gangbang
but stuff say what up Oh
when she showed one of those fingers to
at the end with that he said yeah he
said she's a little long in that [ __ ]
hand rope bro she got some fingers on
her I'm a little confused so he's going
in for a colonoscopy no his girl is
going to school like to be that like
yeah doctor mean let's just start she
wants to work it on him yes yeah mmm
it's not a sexual thing is it no she's
trying to learn now when I was a younger
man I was at this older lady who's a
weather girl and she just knuckle deep
Masshole man
you have to get right to get my mind
right I wasn't ready for it
hey you put my legs up like a baby like
this so big
oh dude she was like this 60% chance of
showers that's crazy I would do girl you
you messing with fire here
oh this slip-and-slide now and I you
know wasn't my thing but I try because I
gotta live bro you gotta live a little
you don't know huh
you don't know yeah go for a hike or
something you have to live a little bit
having somebody hold your legs up in the
air and get inside of your butt now this
was her thing oh yeah well if you want
to cheese caramel own right
I guess there's an assist you know I'm
saying she's Karl Malone can't she be a
woman in the story I don't know any
women I played in the NBA yeah we'll
just don't all right that right all
right I'm John Stockton
she's Dwight Howard first of all I'm
gonna go with just for this guy dude and
second of all this [ __ ] guy bro he's
obviously letting his girl put her
finger in his but this dude this dude
probably as a baby used to put a
pacifier in his butt dude this guy is so
ready to have a finger in his butt it's
insane he put on glasses so nobody would
see him he's on the [ __ ] witness
protection program bruh and he's about
to get pointed out there yeah dude likes
but play I've seen this show does lady
at the end she's sitting down relaxing
he's wandering around making a video at
a Brewing Company she's just not like
this yeah two fingers at the end she
gave a peace sign that's two fingers you
nutcase
this lady's gonna hide all kinds of
secret to you but look at the look on
her face she's in charge suffice yeah
I'm not mad at her at all girl this is
about damn man I know but you know lucky
a nice young lady put fingers in your
ass
what that's what's going on here dude
she looks smart though you make your
money wondering yeah what you guys are
disguise
stick man just cuz you puts their
fingers in the guy's but she's gonna be
making money alive dude unfortunately
right now look man this guy's ready this
dude is the frickin super high this
guy's taking all comers into the old
frickin finger holster let's do Splash
Mountain of butt sex dude just let it
happen well this guy probably will have
three or four rings in his butt by the
time it's all over dude people will be
losing jewelry into this fella it's only
up from here my man yep good luck all
right boys let's wrap it up a little huh
debate club all right man I've learned a
lot I think actually I don't
well we learned how many rats are what
else did we learn Oh Stephen King wrote
Shawshank yep the cat in the bugs which
we had the bug all right with rice
imagine taking a girl to lunch and she's
like where's the restaurant you're like
right here this black pant move gets hit
on a birch and then just boom two bowls
of white rice mmm you're gonna earn it
today girl it's beautiful no this is
this is mother nature there's something
beautiful about that there is there's
something beautiful about that having a
couple bugs with a friend first we got
Dan Weaver from Alexandria Louisiana and
gang brother your 4-pole what's up Theo
what's up Brendan let's gonna be honest
with you guys your podcast is the best
one out there in the world makes me
laugh the most have any podcast I've
ever listened to thanks Daniel
I got a debate club question for you who
wins out of a hippopotamus hmm or that
big old elephant hidden mmm she in my
opinion elephant wins 99.99 percent of
the time but let's see what you guys
think
pinky rein fuzz rug let's go hog dog
fuzz rug I have a pet peeve I think when
people say 99.99% of the time I got it
when you said 99% yeah they keep going
it just and it's nothing against you man
there's nothing to do
with you too my problem mm-hmm so I'm
sorry for thinking that about you cuz
stop that 99 so I went the world is a
vampire done yeah but I went too much
too much I knew it I knew it I knew it
when I when it was coming on my mouth
daniel has that timothy mcveigh beard
peace to man he's got that bomber bra
this dude no you know what I'm saying
this dude Fitzpatrick he looks very
Fitzpatrick the order back yeah yeah he
has every right that's a good that's
Patrick very Ryan Pitz yeah you went
dark well that's cool
he's that come-from-behind guy dude it's
Kyle get it done bro he's that dude
who's gonna throw for 500 yards but
never win a game but one game throw for
seven touchdowns but and not win yeah
just put on all these shitty team
falling out he's also a Harvard graduate
I think yeah yeah smart dude shoutout uh
Alexandria Louisiana over there I went
to a prom up there with a girl from Fort
Polk one time and her dad made us watch
while we kissed each other at the end of
the night the dad watts yeah cuz you
don't want too much tongue and his girl
I don't know yeah that's exactly it you
know pretty easy he wants from pretty
close to he started off kind of further
away then he got close like Joe Rogan at
the weigh-ins bro don't worry can I get
a hit her yeah just like the way is bro
yeah man let you Wayans brothers he's
bright making sure you were gonna slip a
hand on that tit oh yeah well let's go
oh that man yeah he was how old was she
he was in the military and she was uh
she was underage and so was I
you're sixteen sixteen or seventeen yeah
well she one of those sixty or seventy
knows with big old fun bags
cuz that's probably why you saw it I
can't think about that right now dude
it's illegal to think about children
with tits not when you're both seventeen
but I can't be seventeen right now good
point respect where you're going my bed
man cuz that's why the dad so on it you
know yeah yeah that's true if your
daughters set a funbags you don't want
anyone flapping those things around
I can't imagine if my daughter has tits
dude we're gonna have to have a talk
yeah stay here you can go out but the
tits stay at the house after midnight
girl so I'm gonna wrap these things real
tight oh yeah I'm a duct-tape those tits
down boy
dots do oh man take a swing you better
shut it down inside yeah
oh she has any nipples dude because I'm
not this stuff's got to stop dude that's
more of a curse than anything having
nipples that are innies no those are
whatever I'm talking about when you're a
young girl and you're in middle school
or high school and you got you're the
first one to blossom some tits I'm
[ __ ] body rockets bro hey the parking
orbs Brunk and flash [ __ ] hitters out
the front cat did you did you know
anyone with that prom we had a girl
named Danielle and man I felt bad for
she did wear overalls and they were just
oh you know I'm saying your overall she
wore overalls you know whoever it was
they called him big titty she hit too
early man yeah I knew a girl named
Michelle in sixth grade she was fully
endowed like a grown ass yeah and nobody
in her family to make tater Michelle
also known as Wendy Williams yeah keep
going
no one told her that she needed to start
wearing a bra and it got to the point
where it's new you had to go up to her
and tell her that she needed to go home
who her mom to buy her a bra
she freaked out and started crying she's
a sixth grade oh yeah Brendon was a
grade Brendon wait till she gets it
leads to eighth grade dude I felt bad
for those girls cuz I couldn't wait to
walk past her in sixth period
oh there comes tip McGee and then we
didn't see Scribus boner
you don't know what to do dude I let my
sweats oh yeah give it to your friend
hold
like hey bro put the serum what's your
book bags man won't go see won't leave
me alone I'm in trouble
damn you know these double D's dang and
you're crying I'm so they're wet nothing
sexier but we gotta quit talking about
this kind of stuff yeah you're right so
what's this guy want hippos hippo what
hippos versus Hornets yeah elephant I
did hippos all date you know no I'm
gonna get you another thing you know
hippos kill more people than any other
animal in the world
mm-hmm the most dangerous animals on
earth hippos are [ __ ] filthy they're
super aggressive and hippos got that
value up top man they got that uh-oh
that's rhinoceros yeah
oh [ __ ] hippos man nah the hippos
[ __ ] tusks bro and they live in the
water and you see their little ears like
this in the water Nets you know done do
they're under this that's an underbite
Brendon I'm over it man I think I think
these hippos they sound good but they
also seem like they're not doing that
good yeah it could be like a hypebeast
thing you know like hi boys hype hippos
yeah people are like all they're amazing
you get there now like ah yeah it's very
[ __ ] elephant without a tusk yeah
yeah I'm thinking more they're like the
short bus of elephants really I'm mad
I'm out on hippos man I'm gonna say
elephants I've always wanted to feel an
elephant's trunk though 58% elephant not
working well happily you know I'm saying
Britain looks like the kind of guy that
always wanted to feel an elephant's
trunk hold on with one hand or two hands
I just wanna dump them like this oh yeah
I just want to wring his little nose
that you're gonna get I guess I'm just
like feel a mommy dude I love elephants
why you make it all sexual dude um no I
just wanna take his trunk and wrap it
around like Oh crazy man what else we
got you get some rest someone mad doors
last one this is a big man oh wow what
happened he had a vaping accident
stitches or glue what you think was just
cut the knee open in a car accident
reality somebody out here yeah no hear
me out here well I think cartilage or
bone we got a car accident and he wants
no stitches Lulu mmm you gotta go to fix
that could both brothers wouldn't it
part of a bone sticking out I mean
that's a way you don't want for sure
staff you know that doesn't look that
bad it seems like his necks more the
issue that in here do you know [ __ ] up
neck there's nothing you got a neck
brace on the car we drive you know maybe
it's a Civic STI with a fin on the back
bro he's about to get an STI do from the
huggin he doesn't he was gonna get a UTI
in that cut looks like a vagina need you
see it was rough I'm not as Michigan
Wolverine neck brace wow man look man
first of all I hope you're doing healthy
you got the heart monitors and stuff on
obviously you know I thought this was a
vaping accident so I'm glad to know that
that's not work heard
yeah the youth is really into it and you
got to do it if you're running fast or
something you got to be careful if
you're driving a car he said it was a
car car accident I don't know if I
believe that I'm with you I think I
think he was in a vaping Acts and
watching euphoria these kids these days
bro well you're not doing real well man
he caught his leg open and there was no
stitches or glue I do both just double
down bro yeah Oh at this point man
you're already not doing that great so I
would not take any chances with
continuing to not do great I'll also
pretend I'm always search so I get more
painkillers that's why I do that's not
gonna help that you're gonna end up
addicted to those bro and they're gonna
be getting in more car accidents you're
gonna be sitting in even more
questionable videos like liver or kidney
which one do I donate you know which one
do I sell in the black so I think it's
safety first man I think you should
definitely start taking care of yourself
I would glue I glue everything bro
that [ __ ] and then also double up with
the stitches on top yeah and I have a
friend drive from now on man I take it
easy for a little bit just take the
brakes off yourself ask other people for
suggestions on how to live your own life
uber but like you're doing right now
yeah listen to us uber uber with your
heart brah look for the Lord brah uber
that Nick brought good luck dog gang bro
71% went with stitches on that boys and
definitely stitches they can't glue damn
leg crazy [ __ ] up put a zipper on it
2019 man put the [ __ ] metal zipper on
that [ __ ] this ain't red red plus blue
makes green steel bro you got it you got
a really batten down the hatches this is
your damn limb real quick before we go
boys last week we started a new topic
and it was who's more likely mm-hmm and
the results came for that who's more
likely to go to hell between you guys
mmm 67% I'm a big brown damn hey lean
the way bro see you down there brother
I'll be the Pioneer first I get your
[ __ ] sleeping bag nice and toasty bro
I mean which I read and Andy of the hell
bro are you gonna be able to handle it
down there without me for a little bit I
think but yeah as long as I know you're
gonna eventually come down there okay
yeah I'll be down there yeah I'll be
down there
give me just wait for me by the I'll
meet you by the lockers I'll meet you by
in the men's locker hours I what what
movie how are the water fountains nah
bro well I don't I going in there you
got a shower shower once you get there
I'll meet you there bro got your back
you scratch mine in hell buddy whoa oh
man I just wanna will be bunkmates oh
man this is getting worse I might go to
heaven
hell yeah that is that's it boys dude
it's Thanksgiving next week Thanksgiving
we all figure out shout to the lake
monsters shout out to all the lake
monster yeah
where this in I'm in Salt Lake City this
week Thursday Friday Saturday I'm about
to rock this lake monster out there bro
oh nice do the Vermont Lake Monsters
reminded up I want to suck on a maple
tree dude go hard bro do a bog tree well
let me get a boil rice and suck some
syrup
don't go syrup mango something Hardy or
go caterpillar a nice juicy caterpillar
nothing mmm it's a delicacy in some
places man that is like a dumpling in
your mouth yeah yeah maybe all right
dude don't touch me keep it up bro
[Music]